nous sommes très déçus du vote de
suppression de la de la réforme de la
CVAE nous avons affirmé à plusieurs
reprises qu'il est nécessaire de faire
un geste vis-à-vis des entreprises et
notamment de venir diminuer leur charge
de production dans un contexte où les
États-Unis comme l'Allemagne mettre des
moyens financiers très importants pour
soutenir la compétitivité de leurs
entreprises le groupe les républicains
avaient déposé un amendement qui
permettait d'une part d'apporter un peu
d'oxygène aux entreprises dès l'année
prochaine avec un dégrèvement à hauteur
de 50% de la CVAE et pour les
collectivités d'avoir pendant deux ans
en 2023 et en 2024 des recettes de CVAE
identiques à celles qu'elles auraient
perçues en l'absence de réformes et
ensuite pour pour l'avenir comme le
préconisé le rapporteur général nous
demandions au gouvernement de construire
ensemble une réforme efficace et
notamment avec les objectivité pour
s'assurer du dynamisme de reversement de
la TVA et du lien entre territoires et
TVA
[Musique]